DNA origami is a method for making any shape or pattern that you might want
out of DNA.
So the way it works is that you begin with a very long single strand of
DNA,
and the computer program will then generate a bunch of small DNA strands,
which we call staples.
And so the net action of those 200 little short strands of DNA
folds that long strand into whatever shape or pattern you want.
So BIOMOD is a design competition for students
and currently it's focused on college students.
So all the teams come from all over the world and present their projects,
and the idea is to give them hands-on experience in the lab.
Since we're from Japan,
we wanted to do a Japanese origami using DNA origami.
Gene expression mechanisms are controlled by thousands of transcription factors and some of these
processes are essential for life,
but transcription factors can also cause diseases,
so we decided to develop a natural chemical DNA based biosensor that can
be adapted to include the recognition sequence for many transcription factors.
So we wanted to develop a solution towards one of the most prevalent issues facing our hospitals,
which is antimicrobial resistance.
It's in the headlines, particular in Australia, all the time where traditional drugs
are not working as well,
where the pathogens are evolving mechanisms against our normal drug therapies.
So as a team we wanted to come up with a solution.
We looked at the mechanism of cell lysis, puncturing a hole in the
membranes of cells and releasing their contents. And our solution is a DNA
origami nanobot that can puncture bacterial membranes and allow for
its contents to spill out.
So I think nano scale technology is a really awesome field because it's,
I think,
an area that has been under explored compared to other scientific fields. So it's a really hot area right now,
which is why I was really drawn to this,
the whole team was really drawn to this area.
And in terms of why we wanted to use nano scale things in DNA origami,
I guess it's because of its self assembly, so you don't have to spend ages in a lab trying like synthesize
something that has this exact structure.
You can actually just program it and be lazy and on a computer. And then just chuck all the things together,
and it forms really nicely into what you want to do.
So I think it's really awesome that it can do stuff like that.
Which means that when it comes to scaling up things,
I guess it becomes easier.
So if we use this as a direct delivery system,
we can possibly use this to cure some diseases like cancer.
Taking it further into kind of the clinical world,
like seeing how we could try and deliver this to patients,
seeing how we could combat the fact that DNA is degraded in the human body.
So looking at ways we could edit the DNA or protect it
and those sorts of things.
So really trying to apply it more into a clinical setting.